demande pas bon soir alors vous êtes
dans la commission électorale
indépendante ivoirienne dans la tente
comme la population de l' annonce des
résultats officiels du premier tour du
scrutin présidentiel
oui l annonce des résultats officiels
est donc prévue ce soir peut-être aux
alentours de 22 heures un peu après ça
se fera via la télévision nationale
comme d'habitude la rti qui est
d'ailleurs installé vous le voyez
derrière nous c'est studio des résultats
sans surprise le président sortant
alassane ouattara devrait s'imposer à la
faveur du boycott de l'opposition en
tout cas des résultats livrés 48 heures
après le scrutin et hier déjà on a senti
un peu la pression monte ici à abidjan
avec un renforcement de la sécurité
ce matin la villa était beaucoup plus
animée reprise du travail oblige on le
rappelle ce week end la capitale
économique étaient quasi désertes mais
on notera quand même qu'aujourd'hui le
trafic était très fluide d'une commune à
une autre ce qui nous a permis de nous
rendre dans une commune défavorisée et
populaire yopougon kouté
là bas nous avons tenté de parler avec
les habitants beaucoup ont refusé de
s'exprimer devant nos caméras mais pour
ce qu'ils ont fait eh bien ils ont
exprimé la peur qu'il ressentait à la
proche de l' annonce de ses résultats
ils craignent en effet de revivre
nouvelle crise post électorale on
rappelle que celle de 2010 2011 a fait
au moins 3000 morts un mot important
quand même sur la situation dans le sud
du pays
et bien la situation elle reste très
tendue là bas on notera qu'à bouaké le
fief de l'ex chef rebelle guillaume soro
eh bien il ya eu des affrontements
intercommunautaires aujourd'hui autre
fief de l'opposition daoukro là bas on a
noté des manifestations alors savons pas
quelle est l'atmosphère politique
alors le bras de fer entre l'opposition
et le pouvoir s'est durci depuis samedi
en cause le déroulement du scrutin dans
le sud du pays plusieurs régions ont été
empêchés de voter à l'appel à la
désobéissance civile lancé par
l'opposition
du coup le pays on le sait ils déplorent
plusieurs morts mais c'est très très
difficile en réalité de s'avancer au
moment où je vous parle sur un bilan
réel
pascal affi n'guessan et l'ancien
président henri konan-bédié eh bien ils
ont appelé à un gouvernement de
transition civile dont ils ont annoncé
la création
aujourd'hui on le rappelle ils n'ont pas
voté et cet après midi pour tenter
d'apaiser la situation
l'onu devait dépêcher une délégation à
la résidence d'henri konan bédié
du côté du rhdp en tout cas on continue
d'affirmer que rien n'entache la
crédibilité de ce scrutin la mission
d'observation de la cedeao la communauté
des états d'afrique de l'ouest abonde
dans ce sens elle a donné une conférence
de presse aujourd'hui
même son de cloche d'ailleurs du côté de
la commission électorale indépendante le
pouvoir qui réfute un rapport d'une ong
indigo qui indique que 23 % des bureaux
de vote n'ont pas ouvert samedi dernier
par ailleurs plusieurs missions
d'observation électorale note que cette
élection laisse un pays fracturée depuis
un samedi on note vraiment une guerre de
communication fait rage entre le pouvoir
et l'opposition qui multiplient les
points presse tour à tour une guerre de
communication qui est alimenté par les
réseaux sociaux qui publie des vidéos
susceptibles de troubler et d'induire en
erreur l'opinion publique ivoirienne
voilà la situation qui reste tendue dans
le pays
ce soir merci beaucoup savons pas pour
toutes ces précisions samantha ramsamy
en direct
d'abidjan pour retrouvera bien
évidemment pour commenter les résultats
de cette présidentielle